this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
alright so apple just updated their 5k
imacs for the last time
ever with intel chips and they basically
went all out
these new imacs finally compact with
apple's t2 chip
intel's 10 gen processors and new
graphics based on amd's
navi architecture which are all going to
be incredibly important in the battle
versus apple's 5 000
imac pro which is what this video is all
about
now we already ordered the high-end
model with the 10 core cpu
and the top of the line 5700 xt graphics
card
but unfortunately that model won't ship
until next week
so we decided to see how this new 2300
model with the acor cpu and the 5500 xt
graphics card
will compare to the 5 000 base imac pro
that i've been personally using for over
a year now
but a huge benefit of the 5k imac is
that you can
upgrade the ram yourself so instead of
paying apple
six hundred dollars for 32 gigabytes of
ram
we just bought a 32 gig from amazon for
a hundred and twenty dollars
matching the 32 gigs on the imac pro
which by the way uses ecc ram so
definitely buy the ram yourself using
the links below
and we actually have a three minute ram
installation guide video
which you can check out after this video
is over so
this new imac model is less than half
the price of the imac pro
if you add in the 120 price of the ram
so it's definitely going to be tough to
compete with the imac pro
but we might see some very surprising
results because this imac
is packed with the latest technology
from intel and
amd now i know you're gonna say that the
imac pro is two and a half years old
right now
and brand new it now comes with a
standard 10 core cpu
but the current base imac pro that i'm
using
is now valued at around 3 500
if you buy it used without any type of
warranty
so our brand new 5k imac is still over a
thousand dollars cheaper
so this will be a very interesting
comparison so let's begin with geekbench
5 cpu test
but first i want to mention that you can
find our apple product merch
like our shirt or our mask in our merch
shelf just below this video
with this first test the 5k imac blows
the imac pro away
in terms of single core speed even
though they're both
using 8 core cpus and then in the
multi-core test
this new imac absolutely killed the xeon
in the imac pro which is surprising
because there's also a 10 core cpu
option
for the 5k imac which we're going to be
testing very soon now moving on to the
metal graphics test
the imac pro gets a huge advantage in
terms of raw graphics power
since it comes with the more expensive
vega 56 gpu
compared to the 5500 xt in the imac we
then tested the cinebench r20 cpu stress
test
which puts a 100 load on the processor
and the results were absolutely shocking
even though the imac pro has a better
cooling system
compared to the 2025k imac which by the
way
didn't change at all which was confirmed
by owc's teardown
the new 5k imac is scoring 33
higher in this stress test even though
it was only 11
faster in raw processing power in
geekbench 5's multi-core test
this is totally unexpected because
usually there's an even smaller
difference in cinebench
moving on to the unigine heaven gaming
test we see about 10 more fps with the
imac pro
because of that high-end gpu with more
raw performance
so it'll be better for gaming but don't
forget that the 5k imac also has
the 5700 xt which we ordered on the
higher end model
so if you're not already subscribed do
so right now now since that test uses
opengl
i also downloaded gfx bench metal 5.0
and ran a couple of benchmarks in the
1440p
aztec ruins offscreen test the imac pro
got about 30 more fps than the 5k imac
and in the 1440p manhattan off-screen
test
the imac pro scored about 33 more fps
which is definitely a nice difference i
then tested nova bench
and the 5k imac killed the imac pro in
terms of the overall score
which includes the cpu and the graphics
now with all of those benchmarks out of
the way
it's pretty clear that in terms of raw
performance the 5k imac has more
processing power
but quite a bit less graphics
performance so let's move on to real
world tests
starting with final cut pro 10 but first
let me give a huge shout out to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
i built an engaging website for my
wife's cleaning business with literally
no web making experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images
and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable
and it's been running flawlessly for
almost two years
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools
so whether you're making a website for a
small business or for literally anything
else
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and use our custom link below when
you're ready to launch
to save 10 on your first purchase of a
website or domain
the first test we're running and final
cut is the classic bruce x benchmark
and surprisingly the new 5k imac was
faster
even though this is a graphics heavy
test so it seems like the new 5500 xt
is more optimized because of the newer
architecture
moving on to our one minute hevc
stabilization test
we were blown away by the 5k imax
performance
with it finishing over three times
quicker
than the imac pro the reason for that is
because the new gpus in the 2025k imax
use the new navi architecture which
comes with faster hardware encoders and
decoders
for h.264 and hevc file formats
and along with that the 2020 5k imac now
finally comes
with a t2 chip which also helps with
hevc footage
now exporting a 5 minute 4k h.26
clip which is the most common format
that youtubers use
the 5k imac was faster by about 11
seconds
and what was interesting was that the
new 5k imac stayed completely silent
during this export just like the imac
pro which is pretty impressive
and then moving on to a 5 minute 8 bit
4k hevc export
the 5k imac was about 8 seconds faster
so we're getting really great results
for less than half the price of the imac
pro
a lot of people are now transcoding
their 10 bit footage on the brand new
canon r5 camera
so we wanted to see how long this would
take by transcoding a 30 minute clip
and the 5k imac ended up being quite a
bit faster
finishing in 37 and a half minutes
compared to 45 minutes on the imac pro
we then tried exporting a 5 minute canon
c200 raw clip
and this time the imac pro came out
ahead by a good amount of time
the reason the 5k imac was slower is
because it was limited in terms of raw
graphics performance
since there aren't any special hardware
chips that handle raw footage
so for a lot of higher end work that
includes raw formats
the imac pro is still going to be the
better choice
because of the higher raw graphics
performance
but you also need to remember that for
just 500
more you can get the 5700 xt graphics
card
with 16 gigs of vram that will
definitely outperform
the vega 56 gpu in the imac pro
and we'll be testing that very soon now
to finish things off
we decided to do an export test in
lightroom classic
exporting 500 42 megapixel raw images
and the imac pro was the winner but by
only around 47 seconds
this result didn't really make sense
since the 5k imac
is faster in terms of cpu power but the
huge benefit is that in the future
you can pay another 120 bucks and add in
another 32 gigs of ram
if you want roughly 10 more photo
editing performance
so from all those tests that we ran we
can see that even though this new 5k
imac has less raw graphics power
it was actually quite a bit faster in
most of the video editing tests that we
ran
because of the newer hardware technology
we especially saw a big difference in
editing hevc footage
which is quickly becoming the new
standard for shooting video
the only areas the 5k imac lost was in
terms of very graphics heavy c200 raw
footage
and it was also a bit slower in terms of
lightroom classic
exporting but considering that it's half
the price of the imac pro
or over a thousand dollars less
expensive than a used model
this type of performance is incredible
for the price
now i want to remind you just one more
time that this
isn't the top of the line model we
ordered a better one
with the new 10 core cpu and the 5700
xt gpu so we'll be testing that very
soon
and by the way we'll be comparing it to
the 16-inch macbook pro
with the 5600m graphics and our 15
000 mac pro as well so if you're not
already subscribed
click that circle above to do so right
now and if this video was helpful
make sure to check out our apple product
merch like this mask or a t-shirt
down below thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video